so steaming Garfinkel is professor of
history at Western Washington University
and I think he went to award actually
from East and West as coming furthest
because his home base is the farthest
west and he flew in from Italy yesterday
so for this Easter I think so
he was the Travel Award his research
focuses on social and economic history
early Mesopotamia this year not sure he
received the outstanding faculty
Leadership Award at Western he's a
member of the board of directors for the
International Association of Seri ology
in the american oriental society he has
authored and edited several books
including entrepreneurs and surprising
early in mesopotamia and he's a member
of the turtle of the ancient gary's
history and those are just my crib notes
from a much larger on array of
accomplishments that'll work so let's
welcome you're very kind thank you so
much Tara and let me first say I'm going
to assume there's no trouble hearing me
because the loudest place in my
department is the office next door to
mine now I I want to thank you all for
having me and and this is an exciting
opportunity for me I should say for
three reasons as a historian I want to
dig into what brings me here so first of
all I should say that many years ago
more years ago than either of us would
like to acknowledge I actually took a
seminar from professor bullet when I was
a grad student at Columbia so it's
particularly fun to follow that I also
did a significant amount of my doctoral
research in the Babylonian collection
which I understand you visited yesterday
but the the best reason I have for being
here is that at Western we do an awful
lot of training of social studies
teachers in fact a significant
percentage of our major is future
teachers like yourself so I feel
accustomed to speaking to an audience of
future teachers actually fun to catch an
audience where you've already been out
in doing it because my students are all
on the way and some of them saying I
apologize in advance of your middle
school teachers some of them eager to
teach middle school which
is the one thing that I've never quite
understood middle schoolers are scary
now I should also say professor bullets
presentation is a really good
springboard for a lot of what I have to
say I'm not going to talk a whole lot
about wheels I will perhaps talk a
little bit more about animals this might
be the half-assed part of the day and
and you know much of what he said as I
mentioned forms a really good background
to some of the points that I'm going to
make I also may offer some slightly
differing interpretations of the
mesopotamian material so cities as you
well know since you're all here for this
particular Institute were the building
blocks of civilization in early
Mesopotamia the great cities built on
the alluvial plain of the Tigris and
Euphrates River were the most prominent
features of the landscape and this was
certainly true physically the cities
themselves stood out above the
relatively flat landscape in Mesopotamia
and provided people with their most
visible landmarks and I like to
highlight that because we live in a
world where for many of us natural
phenomenon are the obvious landmarks and
we think of man-made phenomenon as being
a much more of a feature of the modern
landscape whereas if we go back to
Mesopotamia
it was the man-made phenomenon once
cities had been built on the plains of
Mesopotamia that were its most prominent
features indeed from at least the late
4th millennium BC onwards the walls of
one city on a clear day would often be
the most visible feature on the horizon
from another city and I bring this up to
remind us how much a part of the
Mesopotamian consciousness urban
environments were politically
ideologically socially cities and here
we should look at at least the
concentration of some of those cities
down in southern Mesopotamia and I'll
come back to this
politically ideologically socially in
economically cities were at the center
of the ancient mesopotamian imagination
and they were at the center of daily
life my focus today is primarily on the
last of these aspects of society
economic life in ancient Mesopotamian
cities but throughout I'm going to
connect trade and commerce directly with
these other areas especially as they
relate to development of the state and
to larger notions of political community
now the prominence of cities is clearly
evidenced in the surviving documentary
record in HMS potamia the most famous
literary work from HMS payment
highlights these points that's what I
wanted the epic of gilgamesh begins with
a description of the walls of the great
city of Uruk Brooks prominence in the
epic and you can see here not only a
description of its walls but the
notation that the seven sages these
ancient mythical figures of Mesopotamia
credited with the production of so much
knowledge had actually laid the
foundations of the walls of what was
early on one of its greatest cities oryx
prominence in the epic of gilgamesh
mirrored its original significance in
the region by 3000 bc uruk was the
largest city in the Near East and
probably the largest city in the world
at that time and this is a fun sort of
comparative map to look at you see auric
on the upper left what this image shows
is the wold size of a bunch of different
cities snapshotted in the eras of their
great prominence
so you see Athens on the top right just
on the verge of the wars against the
Persians Rome the lower right during the
time of the so-called Pax Romana
Jerusalem on the lower left the time of
Herod and up there on the upper left our
city of Uruk and you can see that in
terms of its walled size in 3000 BC
auric was already twice the area that
Athens would be roughly 2,500 years
later and
actually half the size that Rome would
be three thousand years later now just
to be clear were talking about area here
not population population density was
less but work at this time was probably
the largest city in the world it almost
certainly was the actual place as far as
we know where writing was invented and
as a historian I'll depart a little bit
from the discussions of the wheel and
the steam engine and the other stuff
that came in the last presentation and
say that writing was the greatest
invention and as history teachers we'd
be nowhere without the written record
and so Brook
at this time gave birth to the
historical periods of world history and
a return to the epic of gilgamesh the
epic not only highlights the grandeur of
urban civilization but it highlights the
place of the city as the locus of
civilization this is most clear in the
epoch when Enkidu the wild man from the
steppe is being brought into the city is
being slowly introduced to civilization
and he's told come I will lead you to or
up the town square to the sacred temple
to the home of Anu Enki to arise let me
take you to the temple of a onna the
home of a new where men are engaged in
labors of skill and you to like a man
will find a place for yourself and the
text insists that people can only really
be people if they live in a city and
that within that city men find place for
the places for themselves and I'd
highlight because this sets up a lot of
my discussion later on the focus really
is here on socioeconomic places and
indeed ultimately on notions of craft
specialization in the city men are
engaged in different labors in different
skills that's where people will find a
place for themselves and find a place
for themselves in what was as I'll come
back to a very hierarchical community
characterized by tremendous not only
craft specialization but also social
hierarchy and differentiation and I
should also acknowledge here that this
is really a focus in the epoch at least
in this part of the epoch on man
this is not surprising in such an
unapologetically patriarchal society as
ancient Mesopotamia but we should
acknowledge in the text the clear focus
on in many respects the activities of
men and that's not to exclude women from
the discussion in any way but it's to
acknowledge the problem in our original
source material that the focus is so
much on what men do in the urban
environment now before moving more
specifically to the topic of what went
on in these ancient cities commerce
trade the stuff of daily life that is
really the focus of my presentation I
want to give you a sense as teachers of
some of the other resources that are out
there for you for the study of ancient
Mesopotamia as you know HMS pay me today
is located almost entirely within the
modern nation of Iraq and the unstable
situation in Iraq has been a calamity
for the survival of its ancient cities
some of which have become casualties now
of several wars in the region at the
same time to strike at least a somewhat
hopeful note excavation is beginning
again in southern Iraq and in fact I saw
a presentation not long ago on the new
excavations the ancient city of or so we
can now look forward to reports of new
archaeological evidence in the meantime
though as teachers there are a lot of
places you can go online to find some
really neat Mesopotamian things and
things that you can give to your
students the first of them my favorite
the British Museum I should mention only
fair to point out there's nothing
British in the British Museum I don't
have you've been there
it's one of the remarkably named
institutions of the world if it was
called the Museum of British colonialism
the closest of British Museum gets two
british objects is its collection of
Roman artifacts found in Britain so the
detritus of a former era of colonizers
but the British Museum is though one of
the best places to go and in fact if you
just go to right there
it's I think it's just British Museum
org you can do an object search and then
have an enormous number of objects from
ancient Mesopotamia that provide really
a wealth of information about daily life
about what went on in the cities and the
British Museum is kind enough to let you
use those images so you can actually
download really high quality images as
long as you agree that you're only using
them for teaching or other individual
purposes and aren't going to sell them
as postcards now the next place I would
suggest and this is a much more
cumbersome website because it's an older
one and not one that's constant
maintained is something called rather
awkwardly the electronic text corpus of
Sumerian literature fortunately there's
nothing else online that is et CSL so if
you just put in a Google search for ETCs
L you get this rather antiquated website
but what's neat is it has English
translations of any number of the
earliest mythical and literary texts
that we have in the written record all
of the different stories and texts from
early Mesopotamia are provided here in
English translation totally open access
and you can give these straight to your
students send them to look at this it's
an excellent place the last one I'll
mention also I think awkwardly named is
auric the open richly annotated canal
forum corpus again there's nothing else
online that is ORAC see this is actually
a wealth of information if you click on
the project's here this collects all of
the open source projects online that
deal with the canal forum texts from
ancient Mesopotamia and a particular
favorite of mine and of some visitors
perhaps in the room if you go down you
can find virtually everything from I'll
get there eventually the new assyrian
period which was mentioned briefly in
presser bullets presentation and you get
here again open access available english
translations of the very famous new
asturian inscription some of which
mirror the biblical text letters that
you can look at from you know ancient
kings to their ministers from people and
functionaries in their kingdoms back to
them and these are just some really good
totally open-source useful places to go
online or to send your students online
if you want them to look at ancient
Mesopotamia in a little bit more detail
now coming back to Mesopotamia which I
always like to do I want to briefly talk
about the physical environment and press
or bullet again talked a little bit
about this in the last presentation
because it's the physical environment
that sets the stage both for the urban
revolution that took place in
Mesopotamia and for the development of
commerce and in particular long-distance
trade that I'm going to be talking about
it's a hallmark of southern Mesopotamia
usually called in your textbooks the
cradle of civilization then it lacked
rain this is a nice map showing all of
the really healthy I'm told purple I
have to confess to colorblindness here I
like this map even though it's in color
you've got all those really nice purple
places outside of Mesopotamia in the
Fertile Crescent that surrounded
Mesopotamia where agriculture and animal
husbandry first developed here's our
introduction of agriculture map I like
at least with my introductory students
to call this the map of the Fertile
toucan rather than the Fertile Crescent
because just reminds me of the the guy
in the fruit loops box the densest
pattern in there which you see is the
the place where agriculture and animal
husbandry first developed the
domestication of plants and animals in
the Fertile Crescent made possible the
development of cities on the plains of
Mesopotamia and that's why agriculture
comes later to Master taymiyah now in
keeping with what Professor bullit said
I actually want to talk a little bit
throughout this presentation about the
importance of animal husbandry because I
think it's difficult to overstate the
importance of animal husbandry in the
early cities of Mesopotamia and yet I
think it's often ignored and it's
ignored with an emphasis on grain or
cereal productivity this
area which was extraordinarily
productive is usually credited with all
of these wonderful original things in
supposed civilization because of its its
agricultural productivity but the animal
side of that often gets ignored now
certainly the area was very productive
for grain agriculture for cereal
agriculture we estimate based on ancient
texts from various places where they
give the yield on fields that the
average acre or hectare of land in
southern Mesopotamia was between four
and ten times more productive then on a
similar plot for example in ancient
Greece which actually had land that was
relatively unproductive by comparison
but this focus on grain ignores the
importance of animals and in many ways
it's the animals that drove commerce and
you can see on the top here how many of
those important animals that we still
depend on in many ways in the modern
world were first domesticated in the
ancient Near East and here by the way
I'll depart from what Professor bullit
said the donkey the fully domesticated
not half asked not half wild offshoot of
the wild ass of the of the on adjure
bout which he spoke was a very prominent
part of Mesopotamian civilization from
very early on and the textual evidence
makes clear the extent to which they
relied on domesticated donkeys as
primary draft animals and I'll come back
to that in a few moments but more
importantly especially where sheep and
goat are concerned the very
sophisticated industries that arose in
ancient Mesopotamia that allowed for
tremendous commerce to develop among the
ancient cities Mesopotamia
owed its basis to industries that relied
on animal husbandry and in particular
the textile industry now it's also by
now and I'm sure in the textbooks that
you're using something of a truism to
note that Mesopotamia lacked most
natural resources beyond land water and
Reed's this can really be seen on this
map
where the area I'm talking about today
southern Mesopotamia seems to have
nothing and this is a very common theme
in fact stone metal and significant wood
for building were largely absent from
the ancient Mesopotamian environment the
engagement in long distance trade by
these ancient urbanites is usually
ascribed to their need to look elsewhere
for these types of resources this is
certainly true but and this is one of
the readings that I think that Sam will
have distributed to you an article that
I gave to you by a historian at Columbia
by the name of Mark venom Europe points
out that the HMS demons didn't actually
need any of those things from the
outside world in order to be
self-sufficient that the productivity of
the Mesopotamian environment in terms of
agriculture farming animal husbandry the
availability of building materials maybe
not the best building materials but the
availability of building materials in
particular the mud bricks which as
Professor bullet pointed out the master
Damian is used to build virtually
everything all of that was there and in
fact long-distance trade arose in
Mesopotamia alongside increasing social
stratification that is in these ancient
cities as social hierarchies developed
and became more embedded as elites
looked for ways to demonstrate and
perform in many ways their new elite
status they look outside of Mesopotamia
for many of the luxury commodities that
became necessary for elite consumption
and this took place across a really
broad urbanized environment so here's a
good map showing many of the most
important cities of early Mesopotamia
certainly not all of them but you can
see how densely populated this
relatively small area of what is now
modern Iraq was by ancient cities by the
way this here shows what we what we
think is the approximate ancient
coastline one of the big differences
between modern Iraq and ancient
Mesopotamia is the fact that the
coastline was much more in
and a lot of the major cities of ancient
Mesopotamia cities like or were actually
coastal seaports connected directly to
the Persian Gulf and I'll come back to
the trade that they engaged in
throughout the the Persian Gulf and
beyond in a little while but it's
important to recognize these were many
of these cities located right on the
coastline you can see from this just how
densely populated with cities ancient
Mesopotamia was and in those cities what
you had from the period of the beginning
of the urban revolution onward was a
growth in social sophistication social
stratification the growth of a
relatively small group of elites who
dominated the the control of the economy
in these ancient cities and they looked
for ways to perform as I mentioned a
moment ago that status and this is
really important both in terms of its
consequences for commerce and daily life
as well as for state development not
only did these elites drive trade in
ancient Mesopotamia but our evidence
also very much restricts much of our
attention to those elites the majority
of our historical and archaeological
evidence was produced by or for wealthy
individuals at the very top of I'll call
it borrowing from the Egyptians the
pyramid of this ancient society I should
say the ziggurat of this ancient society
but students are always going to be more
familiar with pyramids now in the period
that I'm going to focus on today which
is the Bronze Age in Mesopotamia and in
terms of dates
that's roughly from the end of the
fourth millennium let's say 3200 BC 3000
BC down to around 1200 BC and in the
second half of this presentation I'm
going to focus closely on examples from
a couple of archives from the second
millennium BC to illustrate these themes
of Commerce and daily life but we need
to remember always that these archives
often only provide first-hand knowledge
about a small percentage of the ancient
population
and much of the ancient population in
terms of what they thought about the
society they lived in is hidden from our
view now one of the earliest surviving
objects that richly details this and
which I'm gonna assume many of you have
seen before comes again from the city of
Uruk and it's known to archaeologists
and historians as the ORAC Vaz it dates
to the late 4th millennium BC dates to
around the same time that writing was
being vented in the city of Uruk happens
to be an object with a troubled modern
history as well some of you may know
that this is one of the more famous
objects initially stolen from the
Baghdad Museum following the invasion of
Iraq in the spring of 2003 and it also
is one of the more famous objects that
was returned to the museum it was
returned in pieces and had to be
restored in the modern era a second time
the neat thing about the Vaz or at least
the neat thing I'm going to use the vaz
for is to show more or less in a
vertical demonstration of the hierarchy
this pyramid of society that I alluded
to a moment ago the vaz itself seems to
represent from bottom to top a very
Mesopotamian understanding of the world
that they lived in the very bottom of
the object and I apologize if the images
aren't particularly good you see some
sort of crop growing in the fields grain
flax I'm not I don't know that any of us
are enough of an expert on early
Mesopotamian iconography for plants for
the flora of Mesopotamia to know exactly
what it is but it shows those plants now
they're resting on the water which of
course is the foundation of life in
Mesopotamia and here I'll echo a point
that that professor bullet made and I'll
come back to it in more detail water
routes were much more important to the
Mesopotamians than land routes the
rivers the canals that connected the
Mesopotamian cities to each other we're
much more important in in many ways but
particularly as well for trade and
communication then overland routes and
for all of the reason
that restaurant Overland trade is
significantly less efficient than
seaborne trade or waterborne trade
particularly in antiquity so you've got
water as the foundation of society then
the cereal productivity of the land then
the animals and and we can see here one
of the reasons I'm highlighting the
animals messed humans did so themselves
the animals are next up in this what I'm
suggesting is a hierarchy of their world
view of what we might call the daily
economy that supported their societies
water plants animals and then above that
we finally get people and our first
group of people
first of all tough tell them apart one
thing we can say about them and the
image allows us to say this they're all
men they're all naked they're not
particularly well differentiated from
each other but what they're doing is
carrying the agricultural productivity
of this community they're carrying it
somewhere we see in the next register up
where they're carrying it but we see
here already the kind of emphasis that
we got in a very different context from
the Epic of Gilgamesh where Enkidu is
told come live in the city where you -
like a man can be engaged in labors of
skill these people are engaged in labors
some of it undoubtedly very oppressive
manual labor but they are bringing in
the various produce of that labor and
delivering it up top to the big people
in the centre and this one of the
remarkable things about Mesopotamian
visual iconography about status and
place in society
the more important people are quite
literally bigger and not let me hasten
to add because they were but because
that's the way they were understood in
society they played a bigger role in the
community and so here we see this sort
of socio-economic organization of mr.
Damon society in one alabaster vaz from
you know roughly five thousand years ago
where they demonstrate the way that they
organize their society the ancient
Mesopotamian economy was very much what
economic historians call a
redistributive economy for the most part
the state however we want to understand
that and I'll come back that a little
while own most of the means of
production the people worked those means
of production and they were under an
obligation to deliver most of the
produce of their labor to the state
which then redistributed it outward
unless we imagine this as some sort of
early utopia the way I usually frame
this redistributive economy for my
students is that these people at the top
had organized the system in which from
each as much as they could take back to
them as little as they had to now that's
undoubtedly a slight exaggeration but
I'd suggest based on the economic
evidence from early Mesopotamia only a
slight exaggeration most of the people
worked the land they worked crafts they
worked on behalf of the elites in their
community who then had the
responsibility of deciding what would
happen to all of that stuff and what
happened all of that stuff was that a
lot of it got collected in the center a
lot of it in fact the majority of it was
used locally to feed the population to
provide rations for the laborers who
were working in the fields who were at
other times of the year
fixing the walls of the city about which
Gilgamesh is so proud in the epic of
gilgamesh
they were also producing rich textiles
and other manufactured goods that those
elites could then trade with the outside
world to collect the really valuable
objects that as the article that I
distributed you by Marc van der meer
points out
allowed them to demonstrate their status
the long-distance trade in luxury
commodities is really apparent in the
early archaeological record these are
objects found in the royal tombs the
cemetery at or they date to around let's
say 2600 BC and here we see direct
information not only about the trade
routes that brought in precious
materials like the lapis lazuli beads
you see over here which would have come
all the way from what is today modern
Afghanistan but it also shows us a
little bit about the industries that
crafted those materials into objects
like these these images and the next one
that we'll look at as I mentioned date
to the the end of the first half of the
third millennium BC let's say 2600 BC
and this is also squarely in the middle
of an era that historians today called
the early dynastic period that is the
period during which dynastic kingship
became the dominant norm for governing
the ancient city-states in Mesopotamia
and and I'll return to an object we've
already seen today we see the same sort
of imagery echoed on the standard of or
that we were just looking at a moment
ago on the ORAC Vaz here you see again
people and animals bringing in stuff
stuffs kind of the technical term I'm
going to use for everything they're
carrying and it's everything that's
produced in this extraordinarily rich
agricultural environment in Mesopotamia
and they bring it in to the people at
the center and you can see once again
the elites and here we see more of them
than we saw in the standard of or the
elites are again quite simply bigger
than the rest of them on that top
register you've got harpists and serving
people bringing these elites something
to drink presumably something to eat at
this festival they're having standing up
there as tall as those people are
sitting down and the king himself over
here on the left is so tall that his
head bust through the ceiling
now in this we see again the same sort
of demonstration of how the elites at
the top of society organized local
productivity to have the surplus brought
into the center and then this object
again demonstrates how they used that
surplus to organize long-distance trade
to bring in luxury goods a lot of the
standard of ore is again made of
precious materials that come from as far
away as Afghanistan now the object has
two sides you've already seen a close-up
of part of what we call very creatively
the war side here I'll disagree with
professor bullet it's very clear that
these as he called them war wagons were
used in war it doesn't matter that they
only went forward by the way no
self-respecting general goes any other
direction but more importantly
everything about what they're used for
they're used actually to mirror the
social stratification that I've been
talking about their purpose wasn't like
the chariots of fun modern movies about
ancient Rome to race around at high
speeds their purpose drawn by donkeys
the domesticated donkeys that the
Mesopotamians used for so many purposes
they were drawn by donkeys ponderously
slowly elaborately onto the battlefield
so that the elites could stand taller
than everyone else and I'd suggest
festival it's certainly right they don't
have at this point bow and arrow and use
their using javelin I haven't actually
thrown a javelin but I'm pretty certain
that height is an advantage in doing so
and being brought onto the battlefield
in this way not only mirrored the social
hierarchy that we see here below the big
people actually standing taller on the
battlefield it also certainly gave them
an advantage and certainly an advantage
over anybody who didn't have one of
these mobile platforms to stand on top
of and if we wonder about what happened
to the poor donkeys I think we have to
assume bad things always happen to
donkeys in the ancient Near East and I
should point out these are
these donkeys are not being drawn by a
the sort of bit and bridle that is a
later development most of them are being
guided through nose rings and so we can
imagine this was a rather unpleasant
experience for the donkeys all around
this object again mirrors not only the
social stratification of ancient
Mesopotamia but also its economic
organization and it mirrors as I'm going
to come back to some of the
responsibilities that royal authority
the king they're in the center and in
fact in that image on the top the Kings
chariot on the left is absent of its war
materials because the war is over the
king is in the center again his head
crashing through the ceiling actually
receiving the surrender of the enemy
soldiers or at least reviewing the enemy
prisoners so by the top of this scene
the war's over and I presume they're
ready to turn around again and party now
what we see in these images is the
growing symbolic power of kingship and
this was matched by the growth of
central administrative authority as I
mentioned earlier writing was likely
invented in the city of Uruk it
certainly was invented in southern
Mesopotamia in the second half of the
4th millennium BC and it was invented
largely to track the ownership and
delivery of economic goods we would love
to think writing was invented to capture
the the whimsy or the wonder of poetry
literature etc writing was invented for
accountants it's it's a grim reality as
an economic historian who does a lot of
accounting history doesn't seem grim to
me but I recognize it's not an exciting
tale but writing developed to track the
ownership and delivery of goods here you
see a couple examples of early tablets
again these are fine pictures that you
can download without copyright
infringement from the British Museum
including on the upper right a cylinder
seal also from that their collection
just to show the way in which they used
different technologies at that time to
control and track the delivery of goods
the development of writing was
part of a growth in craft specialization
in these early cities that included an
increased sophistication across the
board both economically and
administrative ly the growth in
industries like metalworking and textile
production were matched by the
proliferation of administrative roles
particularly among the elite including
those that required the specialized
knowledge of scribes and here is a fun
example of that specialized knowledge
this tablet actually is housed in the
the river can manuscript collection of
Columbia University Library I don't
think they're actually as free with
their copyright but I show it anyway the
fun thing about this this is a
mathematical tablet from the early
second millennium BC dates to around
1800 and what it actually shows is a
series of what mathematicians call
Pythagorean triples this is essentially
the proof of the Pythagorean theorem
roughly 1300 years before Pythagoras was
born what it shows us is the way that
these early cities in a trance payment
were centers for the production of
knowledge and I want to highlight that
that knowledge was a direct outgrowth of
an increase in trade in these cities and
its sophistication a growth in the need
to keep track of stuff led to
significant advances in mathematical
knowledge writing gave the ancient
administrators the people who work for
the guys whose head burst through the
ceiling
a greater tool to manage the economy and
this led to a dynamic increase in
record-keeping such record-keeping
provides us as historians with
extraordinarily detailed information
about daily life in these ancient cities
often down to a minut level now again
very much focused on the concerns of the
elite but to give you an example in in
the late 3rd millennium BC let's say
around the 21st century BC which is the
hundred years I like best in all the
world I tell my colleagues in my history
department back home that I'm the first
twenty first century historian they ever
tired but it's not the 21st century most
of them are thinking of 21st century BC
happened to be an era where there was a
proliferation and record-keeping and a
lot of that survives it's so detailed
that for example in the city of or
there's an archive that survives from a
craft workshop where we can document the
daily productivity of that craft
workshop for every day of a single year
so for 4,000 years ago we can measure
what was produced by the way primarily
for an elite audience fancy statues
important or very expensive articles of
clothing leather work etc but you can
observe this today on almost a daily
level for four thousand years ago so
often down to a minut level of detail
they kept records and our knowledge is
further enhanced because the tool of
writing also gave other professionals
who manage trade on behalf of the crown
on behalf of the state a way to better
track their own business in all of these
early ancient cities merchants were part
of the craft specialization that took
place groups of merchants developed from
very early on to manage the trade in
locally bulk commodities we have to
imagine about this redistributed network
of ancient Mesopotamia the big
institutions palaces temples great
estates we're bringing enormous amounts
of bulk commodities raw wool lots of
grain etc all of which needed to be
processed into usable commodities bread
other types of foodstuffs beer in
particular textiles etc all of that then
had to be either distributed or sold and
the way that the is that the great
estates of the time were able to acquire
the other luxury goods that they wanted
was by selling it it was merchants who
handled those sales each of the ancient
cities had a complex local economy based
on farming and animal husbandry the
great institutions collected an enormous
amount of bulk commodities that they
then needed to exchange for other goods
and here I'll really echo where
professor bullet started one of the key
factors to recognize about HMS potamia
is that its serial agricultural
productivity did not lead directly for
trade it may have been an enormous
engine for local population growth but
it couldn't facilitate long-distance
trade because they couldn't ship grain
in bulk anywhere
the reality is overland and again the
donkey is the most frequently used pack
animal in HMS pay me other than people
and very quickly if you load donkeys or
people with grain very quickly they eat
more than they can carry and they can't
carry it effectively over long distances
not only that the Mesopotamian
environment wasn't particularly
conducive to trade on the rivers other
than going downriver or going across one
of the big differences between the
Mesopotamian River Valley and for
example the Nile River Valley is the
best human River Valley is what I would
describe more or less as a one-way
system things went down River now
obviously there are exceptions but
whereas in ancient Egypt the Nile rivers
flow is always from south to north but
the prevailing winds in the valley are
always blowing in the opposite direction
from north to south so that it's rapidly
transited in both directions that's not
true for ancient Mesopotamia and in
terms of it the effect that this has on
history one of the things to think about
if you think about the broad sweep of
Mesopotamian history from Sumerians to
Babylonians later under the Assyrians
keep in mind political power continually
moves northward that's not an accident
or really what I should say is it moves
up River
and that's not an accident because
controlling the waterways ultimately
becomes very important as a key tool of
political control and manipulation in
this environment but it also means
you're not trading all of that wonderful
bounty of barley that was grown around
these Mesopotamian cities over long
distances that made the work
of merchants very important both locally
for the management of that small
regional economy taking those bulk
products turning them into other
products that were more portable more
saleable things like textiles in many
cases precious metal and then organizing
the long distance trade to bring in the
desirable commodities that came from
outside of ancient Mesopotamia now the
work of these merchants also relied from
very very early on on the establishment
of what we might call a regulatory
environment by local political
authorities and here I'll just highlight
as an example the importance of weights
measures and calendars reliable and
agreed-upon and enforceable weights and
measures as well as calendars
facilitated commercial transactions from
sales to loans that were required in
these cities these began as local
systems often unique to each city in
fact in the early historical evidence we
know that cities that oftentimes were
within sight of one another had
different local calendars and different
systems of weights and measures but
within their local economy they used a
uniform system of weights and measures
and in fact this made the early work of
merchants even more important because
their ability to work across these
systems was part of their professional
expertise their ability to put it in
modern terms to translate the shekel of
work into the shekel of Eason like
trading pounds for dollars though that's
a bad idea right now this is part of the
professional knowledge that these
ancient merchants had to have and the
growth of cities and of Commerce
throughout southern Mesopotamia
ultimately then led to conflict amongst
these different cities over both
resources and over these what I'm
calling regulatory systems we see this
by the way in one of our earliest
examples
of historical conflict documented here
we have what is probably the earliest
historical narrative that talks about
both interstate conflict and ideas of
Just War it's the very famous war
between two inch Mesopotamian cities the
cities of roguish and umma this city
here gearson was part of la gosh these
were neighbors what you see here is all
through they're fighting over land a
boundary marker had been set up between
these two states one state this case the
enemy formed a plan to seize that field
broke the boundary marker advanced on
the enemy the enemy armed with divine
right responds but the essence of this
conflict is over both local resources
and their necessity as engines of growth
for both regional trade and
long-distance trade and the growing
importance of a need for greater what
I'm calling regulatory authority the
need for authority to mediate conflict
and ultimately to provide for more
efficient trade amongst these early
States led in part to a process that
historians and anthropologists call
secondary state formation when the
city-states merge into larger political
units when larger ideas of political
community come along now the earliest
evidence we have for the successful
implementation of this larger idea of
community comes from the dynasty of
Sargon of Akkad who's often times called
the world's first imperialist that's in
my view too grand a claim but he
certainly was the first person to bring
all of the cities of southern
Mesopotamia together under one political
organization he created a kingdom that
controlled that whole city this actually
is an inscription on the left from one
of his sons this is an image on the
right of his grandson nerim sin
you can see how grandly the idea of
kingship has grown he's now not just
bigger than everybody else but he's half
the size of the mountain
the important thing here is what you can
see is that Kings are not only taking a
more direct role in warfare much of this
inscription is about warfare the smiting
of cities but it's also about
guaranteeing access to trade in
commodities - to shoe a son of Sargon
says that not only did he defeat these
enemies across the lower sea the lower
sea is the Persian Gulf but that he
quarried the black stone of the
mountains on the other side of the lower
sea loaded it into boats and moored them
at the wharf of Akkad and we can see how
the growth of state authority leads to
increased trade increased productivity
and also larger notions of regulatory
authority one of the other great
contributions credited to Sargon and his
dynasty for Mesopotamia was an attempt
to create statewide standardization of
weights measures scribal practices and
these are all improvements that become a
trope in the claims of early kings of
Mesopotamia among the good things we
provide for you are weights and measures
you can trust calendars you can believe
in other kinds of things that are going
to facilitate trade both within the
cities of Mesopotamia and allow those
traders to better do their job outside
of the cities now the most visible of
these developments both in historical
record and in our modern imagination and
in terms of its impact on Commerce was
the creation of statewide legal systems
the so called law codes of early
Mesopotamia of which Hammurabi's code is
the most famous but certainly not the
first some up both the concerns of
everyday life and those of growing state
authority the example here comes from
that last century of the 3rd millennium
BC the 21st century BC again the best
hundred years in all of history
and it shows exactly what's happening at
that time the city of or down in
southern Mesopotamia had become the
regional power or controlled all of
southern Mesopotamia and what did its
Kings do for the people as it says here
I did not deliver the orphan to the rich
I did not deliver the widow to the
mighty I did not deliver the man with
put one shekel to the man with one Mina
I did not deliver the man with but one
sheep to the man with one ox now by the
way this is for ancient Mesopotamia as
close as we get to a discussion of the
1% Amina the an ancient unit of weight
and measure in Mesopotamia was made up
of 60 shekels so what this thing is I
didn't give the man of one shekel to the
man of 60 shekels not quite 1% but we're
getting close now the remarkable thing
about a document like this and King then
goes on to say and wouldn't this be
wonderful I eliminated em Nadine
violence and cries for justice one of
the remarkable things about these
documents though is that what they do
first and foremost is protect the
property of the wealthy elites the
prologue to something like this law code
the prologue to Hammurabi's law code
make grand claims to justice to
protecting the weak to protecting the
man of one shekel from the man of one
Mina if you then read on in the text
mostly what it says is don't take
anything that's not yours or the weight
of the state will come down on you very
very forcefully and that's critical to
the operation of Commerce in these
communities in fact we tend to think
based on how we in the modern West view
the relationship between individuals in
the state we tend to think of the state
as being somewhat antithetical to the
operation of private property in fact
history of private property says the
opposite private property wants the
state individuals of property in the
community need the state merchants first
and foremost have to have the state to
enforce the standards on which trade is
based in these early communities now
after a period of unity under for
example this king in his dynasty the
Metis taming world fragmented in the
early second millennium for the last
time into a number of small kingdoms
here's just a colorful example of that
that continued to vie for control of the
region and from this same era we also
begin to get really detailed commercial
records from across mesopotamia not only
in the South but also in the north up
here in what is here the Kingdom of Shem
she odd odd we see in the center of the
city of ash or that area which i think
is brown is that more or less right
something like that in that area that's
the place that later on would develop
into the great Kingdom and Empire of
Assyria but in the beginning of its
history the city of Ashur was a
relatively small city-state at the
center of several really important trade
routes connecting the whole of this
ancient world in fact connecting areas
as far away as modern Iran with the
eastern Mediterranean coastline with
central Turkey the city of a shore in
the early second millennium BC managed a
long-distance trade network that
connected families of merchants in the
city of ashore with their
representatives and family members
stationed all the way up in areas that
are today in central Turkey in order to
manage long-distance trade between these
regions by the way a trade that existed
more or less on the backs of donkeys in
the early second millennium this trade
was so important and so lucrative that
the journey from a short econo Sh meant
that a lot of goods were travelling on
the backs of donkeys and not the people
we know that the people actually walked
because the space on the backs of the
donkeys is too valuable for them so the
people walk next to the donkeys and the
donkeys carried precious material
particularly textiles all the knives
manufactured back down here in southern
Mesopotamia traded up here into a short
and then sent over great distances in to
connect and what came back was quite
often copper and silver
and it made this an extraordinarily
lucrative center of trade and we have
evidence for this from the early second
millennium BC not only from the city of
a shore but also from the city of Mari
here on the Great Bend of the Euphrates
that lay astride really important trade
networks connecting the northern
Euphrates valley with the south and
connecting Mesopotamia with the eastern
Mediterranean coastline in fact there
are thousands of texts from the Royal
archives in the city of Mari that
survived they survived by the way as is
so often the case with our
archaeological material because of
terrible tragedies committed by our
ancient counterparts Hammurabi of
Babylon when he conquered the city of
Maribor down the palace and baked the
Royal archives into permanence so that
we have them those royal archives by the
way are so detailed that there's a
wonderful text from the ancient city of
Mari in which the king of Mari who's out
of town sends a letter to his wife on a
clay tablet asking her to remember when
they're entertaining foreign dignitaries
to serve them iced drinks the remarkable
thing about that as we all know Mari in
particular is really almost in the
middle of the desert and so how do we
explain this well they brought snow and
ice down from the Taurus Mountains
on the Euphrates rivers packed onto
barges they brought it into Mari they
packed it underground it's a huge
example in the ancient world the best
one I know of of conspicuous consumption
just so that when they invited people
over they could essentially intimidate
them by producing cold drinks and some
sort of strange dessert that I imagine
must be a kind of sorbet that they were
serving at these ancient palaces now we
have examples then from the early second
millennium BC from what we usually call
the middle Bronze Age then from northern
Mesopotamia and Mari in a short and also
going back down to the south from the
city of ore and here in the interest of
time
I'll use one last example in the city of
or in the period of the 19th 18th
centuries BC we have an enormous amount
of evidence largely because the
excavator the original excavator of or
sir Leonard Woolley this is a drawing of
the walled city of ore here you see it's
great monumental buildings the the
famous ziggurat of ore is that dark
square building there in the centre but
Leonard Woolley also excavated
neighborhoods the places where merchants
and other members of a relative urban
elite lived in these ancient cities and
we can actually focus in on what
happened in even some of the houses of
these ancient cities because the
documentary record from Mesopotamia is
so rich and in fact the one house I'm
going to talk about Woolley called it
number one old Street he named all of
the streets in residential or after
streets in Oxford where he lived and
taught so oddly enough you've got I
think that you've got Church Street over
here this is called paternoster row in
the archaeological productions number
one old Street this small house that you
see right here was a place where a
merchant lived around 1900 BC give or
take a couple of years he worked and
lived in the city around 4,000 years ago
he lived and owned this particular house
he was a copper trader in this moment
the copper trade in southern Mesopotamia
I'll go the other way to a less pretty
map but one that shows what I need
copper trade was centered on the island
of Bahrain which in the ancient text was
called Dillman and the merchants from or
would sail down to Bahrain bringing with
them textiles baskets silver and they
would trade that for the copper that was
so important in Mesopotamia in the
Bronze Age the copper by the way came
from here on the Oman Peninsula
and our records of this kind of trade
are so detailed that we can even see
when things are going bad there's a very
famous example which I think Sam is
distributing to you of a letter that was
written to the guy who lived at number
number one old Street around 1900 BC it
says speak to a Nazi r thus says Nani
when you came you said to me I will give
gimel sin good copper ingots you went
but you didn't do what you said you
place bad copper ingots before my
messenger and you said if you will take
it take it if not go away
what do you take me for that you treat
me with such contempt that you despise
me so and he goes on and on he then
mentions among the Dillman traders is
there anyone has treated me like you
have among this professional class of
individuals whose knowledge allowed them
to undertake these long-distance
journeys the guy who's writing nani is a
local merchant reliant on these
long-distance merchants and what he's
saying is basically you promised me good
copper you delivered bad copper he then
says at the end be aware that from now
on I will not accept bad copper from you
in my own courtyard I will myself take
and select the ingots because you've
treated me with contempt
I will inflict grief upon you so
business could be bad four thousand
years ago just as it can be today the
difference is if folks and this text
even refers directly to the to the
palace it says here on your behalf
we've given to the palace five hundred
forty kilograms of copper by the way
let's put that in perspective five
hundred and forty kilograms of copper
yeah that's a good ton of copper now
what's that worth
by the way it's it's an enormous fortune
it'd be enough pretty much to purchase
the whole neighborhood that a Nazi lived
in keep in mind at this particular time
you could buy a slave for about eight
grams of silver the 500 kilograms of
copper 540 kg of copper at this time
probably worth around you know a
kilogram of silver and think then about
how many people that buys think about
the real estate it buys these are
enormous transactions they're talking
about and what this shows us the end
here because I'll stop in a moment in
the interest of time is how the growth
of state authority both facilitates and
is facilitated by the growth of
commercial authority in these cities
where the growing emphasis on certain
commodities copper being an important
one in the Bronze Age these other luxury
commodities being important to the
elites in these cities especially their
Kings relies on the knowledge that
certain professional groups like
merchants had to such an extent that
although an ox you're subject to all of
these nasty threats and we don't really
know what Nonnie means when he says he
will inflict grief upon him but it can't
be good but the reality is Anton sirs
business carried on and he continued
doing business with both nonny and gimel
sin and this highlights the very
complicated relationship in these early
cities that commerce state development
and the formation of larger notions of
political community had at a time
because this is right on the eve of the
development of Hammurabi's kingdom and
the final creation of what becomes the
kingdom of babylon the unification of
all of southern mesopotamia into a
single political unit that it more or
less remains in and there are ups and
downs over time for the remainder of its
independent history
and the way in which the merchants and
other professionals in the cities help
to forge the state is ultimately as
important as the way in which the Kings
and other figures that we read about
much more prominently attempted to forge
those states on their own and so that we
can have questions I'll stop there